Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Linus ich liebe dich ich habe dir hier einen liebesbrief angehangen.
Agnes ich liebe dich ich habe dir hier ein liebesbrief angehangen achmed ich liebe dich ich habe dir hier ein liebesbrief angehangen alberto ich liebe dich aber die hier einen liebesbrief angehangen alex ich liebe dich ich habe dir hier einen liebesbrief angehangen alexander ich liebe dich ich habe dir hier ein lied.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertvierundvierzig und wir feiern den zwanzigsten geburtstag eines virus der uns so lieb hatte damals das war noch zeiten.
Da waren die viren noch nett die strafverfolgung übrigens auch denn bei war das quasi noch nicht verboten hacking hacking neverland.
In der philippinen ich glaube der junge mann kam ja aus den philippinen und der hat aber dann auch online auf die mütze bekommen.
Ja der hat gekriegt aber es ist auf jeden fall straffrei ausgegangen danach gab's dann irgendwann den computer front und so weiter interessanterweise ich nehme das beispiel sehr gerne.
In vorträgen und so um zu zeigen wie schwierig das für menschen immer wieder ist.
Mit exponentiell gleichungen umzugehen ja also exponentielles wachstum so haben wir ja auch immer wieder im hacking wenn leute sagen ach mach mal automatisch weiter und.
Irgendwie.
Nicht nicht ganz auf dem schirm haben dass sie damit auf einmal im multifrei und im trading landen wenn auf einmal das halbe internet damit beschäftigt ist e-mails hin und her zu schicken.
Ja so war das ja mit allen frühen hackern die haben eine war dann auch mal sehr überrascht von ihrem erfolg so auch der internet wurm der glaube ich noch feuer war der sich so mal durch alle server durchgefressen hat und dann.
Der moritz wurm.
Der moritz warm genau der internet wurm der halt was ich glaube ich die ganze melzer war infrastruktur lahmgelegt hat in den usa,
ja da waren sie danach alle ganz klein laut und wollten das ja eigentlich gar nicht wollen ja nur mal ausprobieren wie denn das so ist ja.
Bei der moritz ist glaube ich wenn ich das richtig in erinnerung der war gar nicht so klein laut der hatte erst noch große fresse so haben sie denn überhaupt gekriegt
also irgendwie schilderung gehen dahin zurück dass er augenzeugenberichte gehen dann zurück dass er irgendwie offen vor begeisterung auf den tisch gestanden hat als er das erzählt hat.
Immer schlecht aber ich glaube das hat ein thorsten und ich auch im im im vortrag beim war das denn vorletzten kongress oder so.
Feedback.
Die viren haben wir das ja haben wir.
Ja wir haben ein bisschen feedback und zwar von p n grüße euch danke für die podcast für dieses mal wieder begeistert wie auch übrigens eine anmerkung zur app und dem was viro logisch sinnvoll oder nötig ist,
meinte ja irgendwann mal im podcast dass es kein wirklichen nutzen hat trosten hat dann allerdings mal ein argument vorgebracht,
ich nachvollziehbar fand bei einer häufung von ein paar fällen in einem kleinen gebiet kommt das dortige gesundheitsamt oder wieder zuständig ist mit dem anrufen nicht nach und man nimmt so die arbeit zumindest teilweise ab,
und eine,
und eine frage wenn die rot-kreuz corona wenn die rot-kreuz corona in österreich von shrimps und epicenter sozusagen abgenommen ist wäre es nicht billig und einfach die auch in deutschland zu übernehmen,
ich glaube da gebe ich ganz kurz eine kurze antwort zu.
Die österreichische app wird ja jetzt auch komplett umgebaut auf das google apple system insofern ist es nicht so billig und einfach die in deutschland zu übernehmen.
Grundsätzlich ist aber natürlich klar dass es sinnvoll wäre international vergleichbare ansätze zu fahren und genau das ermöglichen,
apple und google ja zu ist glaube ich nur zu sagen dass der größtenteils in seinem podcast meinungen äußert und der christian trosten größtenteils in seinem podcast studien einordnet,
ja und auch selber noch aktiv forscht und da ist denke ich.
Zu den meinungen von herrn keko lee ist jetzt nicht die die wiegen
nicht so schwer wie zum beispiel die von trosten zitierte studien science magazin die quasi die immer wieder zitierte grundlage für überlegungen zu,
contact tracing ist.
Ja ich denke der kommentar und überhaupt die ganze debatte die man so beobachtet.
Nürtingen auch mal eine korrektur dieser ganzen erwartungshaltung also diese app ist ja nun total überhalb worden.
Und ich habe vor allem so den eindruck dass,
viele leute sich so ein bisschen falsche erwartungen machen also das geht ja von der totale heilsbringer und die äpfel jetzt alle,
probleme lösen bis hin zu.
Oh das basiert ja auf x y technologie die finde ich scheiße das kann ja gar nicht funktionieren und natürlich das weltuntergang szenario ohr wir werden alle überwacht der untergang ist nah wie konnten wir uns auf sowas nur einlassen wir werden's noch mal den tag x erinnern wo wir über die app
nur diskutiert haben und ich finde das sind alles überhaupt gar keine zielführenden debatten wenn man sie so angeht,
zunächst einmal diese app es in die app die dann letzten endes tatsächlich auf diesem telefon landet,
die ist glaube ich in diesem ganzen spiel noch das aller aller einfachste wir haben jetzt auch eine situation google und apple haben ja.
Für ihre ab jetzt sogar auch sante code veröffentlicht das heißt also rein technisch das was auf dem telefon gemacht werden muss um diesen prozess durchzuführen das ist eigentlich noch der geringste teil und die der eigentliche aufwand ist,
die integration dieses dressings,
in einem tracing prozess der halt im echten leben stattfindet denn,
und das ist glaube ich das uns auch auch hier uns am anfang sagen wir mal haben haben wir das noch nicht so richtig einsortiert weil wir da auch erst begonnen haben uns in diese ganze debatte richtig reinzudenken wir haben ja auch am anfang von contact,
tracking gesprochen dann auf tracing umgeschaltet und es in gewisser hinsicht auch noch nicht so richtig zielführend weil contact tracing ist ja eigentlich,
das was das gesundheitsamt tut und das was auch die gesundheitsämtern auch weiterhin tun werden und vor allem tun müssen,
die sind die orte wo meldepflichtig krankheiten auflaufen und damit natürlich auch,
neunzehn und die starten dann einen prozess der natürlich dann erstmal damit beginnt das irgendjemand der auffällig geworden ist ein test kriegt nachgewiesen wird aha ist krank et cetera und,
diese tracing app sollen halt jetzt helfen,
die sollen helfen diesen manuellen dressing prozess zu unterstützen wie läuft das derzeit derzeit sieht es so aus da sitzen halt leute.
Die mehr oder weniger gut
ausgebildet sind in diesem bereich also es gibt ja leute die das wirklich machen und die da auch einfühlungsvermögen brauchen die rufen leute an die reden mit denen die haben dann lange fragebögen klappern ab wie geht's denen wo waren sie können sich erinnern wenn sie noch getroffen haben also diese ganze recherche ist ein,
grade ich manuela vorgang und funktioniert soweit auch ganz gut wenn dieser fall ein grenzberg ist
also wenn die person sich erinnert mit wem sie sich getroffen hat mit wem sie wo welche zeit verbracht hat et cetera und b wird natürlich nicht zu viele von diesen fällen auftreten und das hat eigentlich jetzt genau der punkt wo,
dieses abbau content creating helfen soll es soll halt einerseits leute waren die,
von der diese andere person gar nichts weiß,
du stehst halt mit jemand eine halbe stunde in der u-bahn zusammen oder im bus eng oder in irgendeiner anderen situation restaurant.
Kantinen gibt's alle möglichen fälle die bereits berichtet wurden wo solche übertragung stattgefunden wurde überhaupt gar keine ahnung hast wer das ist oder wer zu dem zeitpunkt dort war oder wie du die irgendwie erreichen kannst und genau das ist das wo halt,
diese tracing app helfen kann,
wo man einfach sagen kann ok wenn es denn so war das beide ihre telefone dabei hatten und dieses diese diese bluetooth durch die gegend geschleudert wurde dann gibt es eine gewisse wahrscheinlichkeit dass diese meldung
einen kranken dazu führt dass er andere eine nachricht kommt mit vielleicht solltest du mal.
Beim gesundheitsamt anrufen und dich da mal melden oder dich mal testen lassen oder sonst irgendwie also man kriegt damit leute unter umständen mit in diesem prozess mit rein die man ansonsten überhaupt nicht hätte recherchieren können und ich glaube wenn man mit dieser erwartungshaltung daran geht.
Und das nicht zu hoch aufhängt dann dann kann das eben auch ein nutzen haben es gibt ja auch viele debatten darüber ist das jetzt schlimm wenn zu viele oder zu wenig leute benachrichtigt werden man wenn zu wenig leute benachrichtigt werden dann hat sie zumindest erstmal nichts verschlechtert,
dann ist es so wie ohne app gut das will man natürlich auch nicht wenn zu viele leute benachrichtigt werden ja gut,
kann natürlich sein dass wenn man das an der stelle total übertreibt,
dass die leute dann irgendwann sagen war ja alles nur viel warnung und so.
Andererseits haben sie sich vielleicht auch mal testen lassen und das ist zu diesem zeitpunkt auch nicht unbedingt nachteil also ich glaube dass das eben werden kann,
es ist jetzt so dass auch es gibt ja auch neuigkeiten also in dieser front haben apple und google jetzt mal ein bisschen genauer gesagt wie sie eigentlich diesen test,
ablaufen lassen wollen und während halt in den letzten,
tagen und wochen sehr viel über bluetooth geredet wurde und immer so angenommen wurde allein irgendwelche signalstärke und signal laufzeiten werden jetzt der einzige parameter der hier über nähe entscheidet.
Zeichnet sich ab dass diese apps und damit natürlich auch dieses ganze backend ganz andere einflussmöglichkeiten haben wie so ein kontakt wirklich bewertet wird und das eigentlich man die chance hat das so zu parametrieren,
das dieses bluetooth vielleicht letzten endes eigentlich nur noch so ein so ein leichter filter ist mit okay das ist jetzt so der range von leuten die wir uns anschauen und ob dann wirklich ein,
schwieriger kontakt entdeckt wird das hängt im wesentlichen von diesen ganzen,
anderen parametern ab wann war der andere infektiös wie wird es eingeschätzt etcetera und das.
Weiß halt auch darauf hin dass eigentlich die schwierigkeit dieser entwicklung dieser app,
ist mehr ein wie kriegt man diese digitale unterstützung in das aktuelle system der gesundheitsämtern mit eingeflochten also wie baut man das digital ran
wie wie vernetzt man das alles wie fließen da die information wer macht diese bewertung auf welche art und weise welche parameter werden da gesetzt wie passen die sich mit der zeit,
an und das ist natürlich etwas was extrem von der jeweiligen gesundheitsamt infra,
abhängt deswegen glaube ich nicht dass man jetzt,
peace
es wie es in österreich oder in der schweiz oder sonst irgendwo in europa ist einfach so übernehmen kann weil die natürlich alle ganz andere infrastruktur namen ganz andere arbeitsprozesse haben andere hierarchien haben andere formalien haben und
die gilt es im wesentlichen zu integrieren also es ist sehr viel mehr die arbeit im backend als tatsächlich das was auf,
dem telefon letzten endes wirklich programmiert werden muss.
Ja trotzdem muss natürlich auch da was programmiert werden und ich,
denke dass wird man dann jetzt halt sehen also was auf jeden fall der debatte gut tut ist damals zu beginn dieses
erwartungen runter zu schrauben ja also
es ist jetzt nicht so dass die chorona krise vorbei ist wenn diese app kommt es gibt eine ganze reihe an problemen herzlichen dank,
an alle die diese probleme,
erkennen noch viel mehr dank an jene die zu deren lösungen beitragen und.
Ich denke da wird man jetzt also ein bisschen,
in den ersten wochen und monaten die erwartungshaltung unterhalten das erinnert mich so ein bisschen an diese masken diskussion ja wo dann auch irgendwie
anfangs behauptet wurde maske bringt nix irgendwann hat man dann gesehen na ja wenn man es mal versucht hattet auch bisher kein geschadet
und so weiter und so fort und das ist eben hier jetzt auch eins niemand denke ich ist da vollständig irgendwie auf der ebene das,
als als ideal lösung aller probleme zu sehen das hindert natürlich nicht daran dass einfach immer wieder anderen vorzuwerfen.
Und es könnte einfach überhaupt ein
ein guter erster schritt sein für noch umfangreiche lösung also es ist ja hier noch so an einiges einiges denkbar wie man eben so eine
eine eine anonymität waren der erfassung der gesamtlage mitgestalten kann da werden wir sicherlich noch neue ideen und entwicklung sehen und das wird uns sicherlich dieses jahr noch auf trab halten.
So dann haben wir einen kommentar von dave hallo könnt ihr logo freiheit bitte als podcast veröffentlichen merci
ja also eigentlich mache ich ja youtube projekte weil ich was bei youtube machen will aber ich hatte meinen abend zeit und habe dann einen kleinen,
youtube graper gebastelt der direkt eine statische website daraus baut mit audio feed.
Das habe ich veröffentlicht auf geht's,
also es ist wirklich kein kein kein code gedicht aber es funktioniert und zwar funktioniert das primär weil es mit octopuz sowieso in statics generator gibt und die aufgabe besteht einfach nur darin,
sich mit youtube halt mal mit den metadaten zu holen mit f mal eine audiodatei zu kreieren und das ganze dann in form von magda und dateien wieder rauszuwerfen die oktopus verdauen kann.
Und das war dann doch relativ einfach möglich deswegen gibt es das jetzt auch als podcast feed ohne kommentare und ohne,
großartige pflege und garantie auf verfügbarkeit und so weiter aber wer wer youtube bei sich im im server geblockt hat kann das dann eben auch als audio.
Dann gab es einen kommentar von kai etwas längere kommentar,
erstmal großes danke an das netzwerk team macht weiter so heute bin ich bei der faz über diesen kommentar eines journalisten gestolpert und erinnere mich gleich an diese logbuch feuerwehr,
link
ohne in verschwörungstheorien abdriften zu wollen kommt man nicht umher der faz ein narrativ zu unterstellen oder zumindest den versuch eines aufbauen zu wollen welches dann vielleicht in den nächsten tagen und wochen abgearbeitet wird natürlich ist ein kommentar kein ausführlicher artikel aber man.
Aber wenn man mehrere zeitungen nachrichten und euren podcast verfolgt dann merkt man schon wie manche dinge doch recht stark polemisiert und überspitzt dargestellt werden.
Tat die bürger unterscheiden oft nicht zwischen der expertise und dem
wismut der hacker das ist ein grund warum die nerds in deutschland so viel macht haben ein anderer ist dass sie als herrscher des internets gelten und damit auch des shitstorms sie können es regnen lassen mit solchen leuten möchte man sich nicht anlegen.
Zitat ende aber.
Allmächtig allmächtig.
Ich werde.
Weiter geht's aber der david in klammern faz wird es zum glück mit dem goliath in klammern nerds aufnehmen das wird ja sicher klicks generieren insofern verfolge ich gespannt und mit eingeschalteten app blocker was die faz nächster zeit für content generieren wird.
Das prädikat nachrichten werde ich dem vielleicht erst danach geben ja in der tat.
Muss ich sagen dass mich die veröffentlichung der faz auch einiger weil einigermaßen ratlos zurücklassen das fing ja an mit diesem kommentar von konstantin von linden der den cd c erpressung unterstellt.
Es ging dann weiter mit jasper von alten bochum der nicht den unterschied zwischen zentral und dezentral versteht,
denkt dass der c sich der nun von google und apple adaptierte dezentralen lösungen in den weg stellen würde.
Und dann kam jetzt dieser kommentar eben von morgen freitag die haben aber auch echt ehrlich gesagt ich glaube das sind alles bei der faz wenn ich ehrlich sein soll die haben sich doch wie willst du heißen ja martin freie okay.
Hallo.
Ich heiße jasper von alt bock der war gut.
Wirklich so wie wie ihr wie die pferde und über bei bei metro laut irgendwie naja egal,
was der morgen freitag übrigens auch schreibt und jetzt um eine kurze den kontext zu setzen auch wieder zitat.
Es hat dazu geführt dass die bundesregierung einknickt e und nun eine zahnlose app programmieren lässt die
alles dem nutzer überlässt er kann die app herunterladen oder nicht er kann andere waren wenn er infiziert ist oder nicht er kann zu hause bleiben wenn er vor einer infektionsgefahr wurde
oder weiter im bus zur arbeit fahren man kann sich ausmalen wie gut das funktionieren wird die behaupten die behörden hätten heimliche absichten in wahrheit sind sie es die ihre,
offenlegen sollten.
Ist jetzt aber mal raus mit deinen motiven ja.
Ja genau also.
Du hattest das ja schon getwittert das fand ich sehr gut diese app ist nicht zahnlose sie kann einen nur nicht mehr beißen ja und das ist besser kann man glaube ich die funktion der einer dezentralen app nicht.
Bezeichnen wenn er sagt aber jetzt sehr schön was sind denn die alternativen erkennen die app herunterladen oder nicht mit anderen worten morden friday hätte gerne eine zwangsarbeit,
er kann andere waren wenn er infiziert ist oder nicht mit anderen worten hätte gerne eine zwangshandlung.
Er kann zu hause bleiben wenn er vor einer infektion gewarnt wurde oder weiter im bus zur arbeit fahren da haben wir diesen aspekt
der natürlich auch eine also den man sich in asien sehr gut abschauen kann nämlich quasi die digitale fußfessel app also
probe anrufe oder fencing sodass die app halt theater macht wenn du trotz alarm weiter vor die tür gehst ja also.
Eine erstmal wirklich ganz.
Ja haben wir mit dem mit dem grundgesetz jetzt nicht ganz so einfach in übereinstimmung zu bringen der ideen die der herr friday da unter,
unter seinem synonym gehe ich jetzt mal von aus verbreitet.
Außerdem finde ich das sehr spannend dass also das war ja schon bei dem artikel von.
Jasper von alten borkum der fall dass sie nicht verstanden haben,
dass der ansatz der jetzt gerade von google und apple adaptiert wurde.
Der dezentrale ist und auch nicht verstanden haben welche rolle dann in dieser diskussion eben auch.
Apple und google zukommt denn es ist nun mal das ist also dass wir einfach eine eine fakten beschreibung es ist nicht möglich eine contact racing app zu bauen die in der breite der bevölkerung,
verbreitung findet und realistisch unter realbedingungen funktioniert nämlich im hintergrund immer.
Ohne dass apple und google das unterstützen das heißt was hier tatsächlich geschehen ist wenn der cfc hier irgendetwas,
beigetragen hat dann unter umständen seine stimme so zu erheben dass es bei google und apple angekommen ist ja denn die sind diejenigen die nun diktieren.
Wie contact tracing auf ihren geräten möglich ist und wie nicht ja da hat der cfc relativ.
Wenig mit zu tun jetzt glaube ich dass sie bei der faz aber quasi genauso ungerne große konzerne kritisieren wie sie die regierung kritisieren und in diesem fall jetzt,
gesagt haben na gut dann dann gehen wir halt den c die schuld leider muss ich sagen dass das.
Ich finde das eigentlich immer schön wenn leute.
Eine andere meinung vertreten ja ich habe ja hier gerade in diesem podcast immer sehr stark auch die argumente.
Gewürdigt und gesprochen die für einen zentralen ansatz.
Sprechen bis zu einem punkt dass irgendwann hier in den kommentaren so linus bist du jetzt für zentral oder dezentral.
Entscheide dich.
Entscheide dich auf welcher seite stehst du ja und das ist leider ziemlich genau das was hier auch in dieser passiert dass eben nicht.
Das thema sage ich mal,
vernünftig erneuert erörtert und beleuchtet wird ja und der hat also sehr offensichtlich den kommt die komplette auseinandersetzung die kräfteverhältnisse hier nicht verstanden außerdem muss ich jetzt mal ganz ehrlich sagen.
So kooperativ wie in dieser angelegenheit war der c selten
der c hat angefangen damit einfach eine eine bank hundertdreiundvierzig
dänemark abzubuchen und die dann kooperativ wiederzugeben ja aber vorher wurde erstmal abgebucht also unsere normale vorher,
vorangehensweise ist wenn uns etwas nicht gefällt dann lassen wir die das erstmal fertig bauen und machen's dann kaputt
ja und sagen nicht vorher bescheid und das ist doch schon mal also da muss man nutzt da auch mal ein punkt für geben ja ich habe schon im märz den dezentralen ansatz von contact tracing vertreten
der übrigens.
Von also wo es noch gar keine großartigen diskussionen über zentrale ansätze gab ja peppi hat sich danach irgendwann wochen später der öffentlichkeit vorgestellt.
Wir haben zehn prüfsteine veröffentlicht die von jedem,
also ich kenne niemandem der an diesen zehn prüfstein irgendwelche,
fundierte kritik geäußert hätte ich ich höre von allen dass diese prüfsteine sinnvoll sind berücksichtigt werden und so weiter ja das war übrigens bei peppi genauso der fall wie,
bei wie bei den jetzigen jetzt jetzt zu jetzigen zeitpunkt verfolgten projekten wir haben,
im gegensatz zu vielen anderen dem benefit of bedauert gegeben dass diese ganze sache etwas bringen könnte ja also wir haben,
es gibt ja auch einige die jetzt etwas
hemdsärmlig in diese diskussion einsteigen mit vielleicht nicht ganz so belastbaren argumenten dann nochmal sachen kritisieren also eher so argumente aus dem
ich würde jetzt sagen ich eher so am anfang april verordnet würde alles super ja da haben wir alles brav mitgespielt ja wir haben einen ansatz vertreten der das der so überzeugend war ja,
und wie gesagt wir haben den ansatz der nicht mehr erfunden dass google und apple sich vereinen ja und dokumente rausgeben wo draufsteht apple und google ja was mir auch nicht bekannt ist dass es so etwas schon mal gegeben hätte und.
Ich glaube,
das kann die faz einfach nicht dulden die braucht eine klare ordnung der feindes linien und entlang dieser muss jetzt weiterhin operieren also dieser artikel ist leider leider eben.
Ja dumm.
Ja vor allem es ist ja auch so ist es gab aber auch bei vielen bisher gab es ja ein artikel darüber wie dieses projekt bei apple und google überhaupt zustande gekommen ist.
Hast du's gesehen und daraus kann man halt ablesen also das ganze ist bei apple gestartet google wurde zwei wochen später mit dazu geholt.
Und während apple halt dieses modell ausgearbeitet hat haben die sich vor allem von dem kryptographie modell von.
Lassen so das heißt tatsächlich kann man auch mal sagen dieses modell was jetzt über diese welt abgeregnet wird.
Genau ist eine europäische forschungsleistungen schweiz deutschland waren verschiedene gruppen mit da drin ja also die haben im wesentlichen dieselbe idee gehabt so
konkret wurden dann aber eben auch viele ideen aufgegriffen die die anderen gemacht haben und das ist finde ich.
Auch schon mal interessant da musste gar nicht so viel gemacht werden.
Ja also das so das was da jetzt stattgefunden hat bei diesen korona tracing ne,
das ist ein diskurs wie gesagt die ich habe ja auch kritisiert dass diese diskussion irgendwann mal entgleitet ist zumindest in der öffentlichkeit wo es dann irgendwelche twitter zankereien gab und so das ist natürlich
unsinn aber insgesamt wurde war das hier ein eine sehr ausführlicher fachlicher diskurs und das ist halt dann.
Schade wenn da leute unter pseudonym irgendwelche unqualifizierte hetze betreiben,
das haben wir genug im internet und dafür braucht man nicht auch noch so eine abiturienten bravo und das ist einfach bedauerlich.
Hört republik deutschland stell dir mal vor wenn wir hier insgeheim in deutschland regieren würden wie es in diesem artikel insoliert wurde wir hätten die letzten zehn zwanzig jahre ausgesehen linus das wäre doch ein ein ein schlaraffenland geworden.
Würde ich so wirklich sofort klarnamen pflicht bei der fatz durchsetzen.
Jetzt schockiert du sie aber jetzt leben sie in angst.
Und.
Nee also das ist das ist wirklich schade schade wenn wenn eben der die politischen politischen zusammenhänge hier nicht recherchiert werden.
Okay.
Ich habe mir gedacht weil ich gerade so ein bisschen darüber nachgedacht habe wie wir dieses thema hier begleitet haben dachte so,
weil was jetzt passiert ist letztendlich haben wir in diese ganze contact tracing geschichte.
Weiß nicht wie du das siehst tim aber als wir vor das war glaube ich auch noch im märz die contact tracing sendung gemacht haben unter dem titel korona tracking,
da haben wir so ein bisschen gedacht ok das ist jetzt irgendwie mal eine eine wichtige sendung das thema wird die welt länger begleiten und wir haben jetzt hier schon mal viele wichtige dinge zugesagt.
Mir fällt leider auf das selbst dieser diskussion stand den wir da dann schon irgendwie besprochen haben in der breite der gesellschaft,
bis heute noch nicht so ganz angekommen ist jetzt einerseits muss ja auch also das ist erstens nichts nichts besonderes also nicht nicht,
besonders irre weil wir sind halt irgendwie eine fachverband sicherung und nicht eine mainstream veröffentlichung insofern ist das klar das themen irgendwie in den kontexten netzpolitik org logbuch netzpolitik beim chaos computer clip.
Früher eröffnet erörtert werden als sie irgendwo in der mitte der gesellschaft dann irgendwann mal thema werden oder auch vielleicht gar nicht thema in der mitte der gesellschaft werden.
In der regel fünf bis zehn jahre vorher.
Ja unten naja genau jetzt oder in der corona eben nur ein ein monat vorher,
und jetzt andererseits muss man sich natürlich auch nicht wundern weil solange diese öffentlichkeit informiert wird von solchen leuten wie in der faz brauchst dich auch nicht wundern wenn die debatte in der öffentlichkeit im monat länger braucht bis sie irgendwann mal qualifiziert stattfinden kann.
Aber mir ist aufgefallen ein anderes wirklich gutes beispiel war die copyright direktive da haben wir hier mit der julia reda ich weiß nicht jahre vorher darüber gesprochen,
als dann irgendwie über die eu copyright reform gesprochen wurde haben wir hier und dann wurde es irgendwann als das ding dann kurz davor war.
Ja uns allen im gesicht zu explodieren wurde das dann großes thema lange rede kurzer sinn das spricht erstmal für unser programm also offensichtlich behandeln wir die wichtigen themen auch immer mit zuerst.
Aber es belastet auch so ein bisschen mein widerwillen mich am laufenden band zu wiederholen das also ich habe,
tatsächlich kaum noch lust über dieses contact tracing zu sprechen während das gewissermaßen jetzt gerade auch nochmal,
ein bisschen notwendig ist ich habe aber gemerkt dass auch mehr,
mehr und mehr in so social media diskussionen dann gerne mal auf uns verwiesen wurde ja so irgendwie mit hier übrigens pass auf du,
liegt da ein irrtum auf den unterschied hat logbuch netzpolitik hier erklärt mit link das freut mich
das ist schön dafür zeichne ich dass ihr hier auf damit ich mich nicht andauernd wiederholen muss insofern freue ich mich wenn,
wenn ihr das uns in social media diskussion weiterempfehlt und wir hoffentlich dazu kommen.
Klügere schneller klügere diskussionen zu führen.
Eine andere sache die ich mir so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist als ich letztens über die das logbuch in zeiten des,
corinna signierte war dass ich dann doch relativ viele antworten bekommen habe er persönlicher natur zu denen zu meinen einlassungen zur depressionen prävention.
Also viele freundliche antworten die so sagen jo habe ich beachtet hilft mir und so das finde ich sehr schön und.
Das freut mich dann natürlich auch ich hoffe euch gehts weiter gut ich persönlich bin auch immer ich bin auch stets bemüht meine eigenen empfehlungen zu befolgen.
Und kann da inzwischen auch recht einfach so also es macht spürbare unterschiede wenn man das mal einen tag nicht macht insofern kann ich euch da,
nur ermutigen weiterzumachen andere sache die jetzt ein bisschen die leute glaube ich gerade runterzieht ist das
ja sowas wie die ganzen großveranstaltungen festivals und so jetzt irgendwie mal dieses jahr ausfallen wir haben die fusion abgesagt wir haben so ungefähr jedes andere festival abgesagt was es gibt es.
Mehren sich die zweifel.
Dass es im jahr zwanzig ein kehrst communication congress als präsenzveranstaltung geben kann die entscheidung wird aber,
einfach weil der point of no return noch nicht da ist sicherlich noch erst in einigen monaten getroffen werden.
Und ich merke denke viele leute die ich stelle fest dass viele leute so irgendwie in die nächste zukunft.
Also ein eine schwarze dunkle zeit blicken ohne feste ohne veranstaltungen und so weiter und ich glaube ehrlich gesagt.
Dass gerade eine ganze menge kreative energie die vielleicht in diesen veranstaltungen auch gebunden war,
frei wird ja ist ja nicht so dass eure festival veranstalterinnen und supporter und freundinnen und freunde mit denen ihr dat hingeht,
jetzt gerade nichts was anderes zu tun hätten ganz im gegenteil die haben jetzt teilweise sehr viel mehr zeit auch eine ganze menge kreativer energie die sonst gebunden war jetzt irgendwie an anderen stellen freizusetzen und,
zum beispiel gab es jetzt irgendwie ich weiß gar nicht was schädlich ja vergessen welcher stadt das war da gab es ein drive fast das gesehen.
So und dann wurde dann auch im bei einigen meiner freundinnen und freunde so ein bisschen die nase gerümpft ne so mein gott wenn das jetzt die zukunft ist mal so wo ich mir dann irgendwie so denke.
Ja weißt du,
so kann man sich das auch alles kaputt reden weil natürlich wird das nicht so geil wie ohne corona irgendwo auf einem schönen festival in der natur ist richtig.
Aber das wird halt anders geil.
So ich ich wäre froh gewesen bei diesem auto rave zu sein ich es hat eine ganze reihe einschränkungen.
Und wie sie sagt man so schön kreativität ist tanzen in
in fesseln oder sowas ja und ich ich glaube da wird einfach noch viel passieren da wird noch da wird noch viel entstehen was was menschen noch
so jetzt machen um kreativ mit diesen kram umzugehen ich sehe das in protest bereich und ich sehe das auch im feier bereich und ja
das ist alles anders ja das ist alles nicht so geil aber ich bleibe dabei das wird eben anders geil.
Ja genau korona rave ich war dabei das sind auch die shirts die sich später gut verkaufen ja.
Also ich glaube da geht noch was und.
Abgesehen von diesen bekloppten hippies die natürlich jetzt irgendwie mit virus antivirus messages auf irgendwelchen plätzen sich demonstrativ umarmen und abknutschen das muss jetzt nicht.
Ich arbeite weißt du ehrlich gesagt die finde ich auch geil finde ich so witzig guck mal das würde mich auch betrüben wenn ich nicht irgendwie morgens.
Was weiß ich nachrichten aufmachen kann und ein paar voll hirn verbrannte sehen würde die die was weiß ich in hygiene fest feiern das doch auch witzig.
Ja nur dass die sich halt irgendwie mit den ganzen anderen bekloppten zusammenschließen und sich dann letzten endes wieder von so rechten vollpfosten mitreißen lassen.
Tim das haben wir aber sonst auch gemacht.
Das ist doch nicht so als wäre die vollpfosten erst jetzt durch corona zu vollpfosten geworden der corona hat uns nicht die vollpfosten gebracht die hatten wir schon vorher da.
Aber der spürt sie wieder nach oben.
Ich glaube ich glaube die schwimmen einfach oben also ich glaube nicht dass das dass da die werden auch ohne corona hätten die was anderes gefunden die müssen ja auch mit ihrer energie irgendwohin.
Na ja gut wenn sie nach oben treiben und und man sieht dann besser abschöpfen und entsorgen kann dann meinetwegen aber schön ist es auch nicht.
Alle bekloppt sag ich immer nur alle alle alle bekloppt.
Außer wir deswegen logbuch netzpolitik like zu skype spenden klingel.
Und was nicht alles so okay.
Es gibt so ein paar gedanken zur rechtlichen regelung des contact tracing und ich habe da nicht anfangs dachte ich so.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich gut oder schlecht,
wenn leute beginnen sich in diesem bereich rechtliche regelungen zu überlegen na weil das das risiko ist dass es dann irgendwie in richtung einer verpflichtung oder sonstigen gehen kann,
das andere risiko ist ließ ich mich dann von den expertinnen belehren wenn man das nicht rechtlich regelt.
Das dann unter umständen.
Tatsachen geschaffen werden können die man so gar nicht haben möchte ein beispiel was wir da genannt wurde war.
Toll collect als diese maut stationen aufgestellt wurden ja da gibt es ja gab es dann natürlich auch.
Das problem oder die befürchtung dass diese für lkw-maut gedachten mault station auf den deutschen autobahnen technisch in der problemlos in der lage sind so eine kennzeichenerfassung zu machen wie sie.
Eben eine also wie sie nicht vorgesehen ist für tolle collect und sie das aber natürlich klar ist dass dass es etwas ist was.
Polizeibehörden gerne machen andere meister hat und da bei uns auch schon vor ein paar jahren mal drüber gesprochen.
Und die lösung war natürlich einfach in einem gesetz festzuhalten dass es eben kein polizeilichen zugriff auf diese daten geben kann punkt ende fertig aus und,
wenn man so etwas nicht macht dann bist du eben im bereich des telemediengesetz es wenn ich mich da nicht täusche und der strafprozessordnung und dann gibt es eben diese zugriffe.
Ja ist ja das gleiche was leute jetzt merken wenn sie sich irgendwie so ein.
Sondern alexandra ins haus stellen ja der dass sie dann
feststellen ach shit ich rede gar nicht mit dem ding sondern ich rede mit der cloud und die cloud unterliegt eben bestimmten gesetzen und daten auskünften und ist es für die polizei problemlos möglich die aufzeichnung von meinen,
von meinen privatgespräche mit meinem dreißig euro lautsprecher mit cloud anbindung,
abzugreifen ja das ist eben quasi genau dieser aspekt es kommt eine neue technologie in alte rechtliche framework und da ist es manchmal eben die klügere idee tatsächlich diese neue technologie mit einer.
Mit einem gesetz zu begrüßen,
und da gibt es jetzt das wird denke ich komm also ich höre das sowohl aus den.
Aus den bundestagsfraktionen dass man sich darüber gedanken macht als auch aus der sagen wir mal.
Weitesten sinne aktivistische aus dem aktivistischen bereich der hat mir der ralf benrath so ein beispiel geschickt an dem er auch beteiligt war ralf benrath ist uns ja allen bekannt als der.
Ehemalige mitarbeiter von jan philipp albrecht jan philipp albrecht der bei uns in der sendung,
gast war zum tag des inkrafttretens der datenschutzgrundverordnung die beiden über die beiden gibt's auch diesen film democracy im rausch der daten sehr zu empfehlen der film und ralf benz ist denke ich seit,
aber mindestens zwei jahrzehnte sagen wir mal anderthalb bis zwei jahrzehnten eine kapazität im bereich des des datenschutzes und sowohl aus technischer als auch.
Rechtlicher perspektive.
Der weiß bescheid.
Der hat da kennt sich mit dem thema aus morden hast du gehört.
Kann man sagen.
Und
wir haben also jetzt hier einen vorschlag für ein gesetz zur einführung und zum betrieb einer app basierten nachverfolgen von infektionsrisiken risiken mit dem saß kopf zwei corona virus formuliert sind insgesamt drei,
autorinnen ninja manaus ist dabei ist eine privacy security forscherin am cispa in saarbrücken.
Also durchaus einige gedanken mit drin und.
Es geht los mit festhalten der freiwilligkeit was ich nämlich auch ganz interessant finde weil wenn du wenn du sagst das ding ist freiwillig ne dann heißt es glaube ich,
konsequenz auch dass halt jegliche privaten zwangsmaßnahme eben irgendwie unter.
Unterbunden werden können dann der betreiber soll geregelt werden nämlich das robert koch institut wir wissen dass das insbesondere hier bei den diskussionen um den zentralen ansatz da wollte niemand die heiße kartoffel der der verantwortlichkeit auch haben.
Dann wird das verfahren einmal beschrieben und ich denke das verfahren ist.
Ist wichtig ja weil es weil da ein in meinen augen entscheidender punkt nämlich eine rolle spielen wird den wir auch in den letzten sendungen schon immer wieder angesprochen hatten was ist die konsequenz eine alarmierung und insbesondere wenn wir davon ausgehen.
Dass es eine,
das ist voll geben wird ja dann halte ich das für sehr sinnvoll auch die konsequenzen,
dafür relativ klar zu halten nämlich im positiven bereich nämlich zum beispiel zu sagen wenn die app dich alarmiert gewinnst du einen kostenlosen corona test punkt,
du kriegst nicht,
besonders schwere negative konsequenzen die autorin und autoren beschreiben aber hier viel mehr dass das technische verfahren um quasi auf festzuhalten dass es ein dezentrales verfahren ist.
Löschung der daten bei installation wir erinnern uns wäre nicht so einfach bei.
Bei der corona datenstände app also alles was hier steht hat auch immer sein,
seine sein auslöser zweckbindung das haben wir damals als wir die co prüfsteine formuliert haben auch spezifisch mit reingebracht dass wir gesagt haben diese app,
dient dem zwecke der eindämmung der saß zwei pandemien,
wenn du das nämlich nicht da rein schreibst und schreibst irgendwie so einen satz rein wie zur nachverfolgen von infektionskrankheiten dann hast du als nächstes halt noch ganz andere apps auch hier.
Auf solche ideen kommst du halt aus erfahrung datenschutz folgeabschätzung und zusammenarbeit mit dem bsb,
klar und sagen halt diese ergebnisse sollen auf geeignete weise veröffentlicht werden
generelle veröffentlichungen transparenzpflichten auch das haben wir jetzt damals schon gefordert und hier eigener speck,
eigener absatz paragraph zehn recht auf test und vorgehen im falle eines positiv testes erhält eine nutzenden person durch die app eine
benachrichtigung über eine infektionsrisiko so hat sie anspruch auf einen unfall auf eine infektion.
Im falle eines positiven tests erhält die infizierte person unverzüglich den freistaat code andere zu alarmieren.
Es besteht keine pflicht die identifizierung in der app zu registrieren insofern gilt paragraph zwei entsprechend ja morgen.
Da hast du was zum aufregen,
und sie sagen dann hier noch es solle alternative apps geben ja das dritte anbindung also ebenfalls an dem verfahren teilnehmen können,
diese dritte anwendung für erfüllen mindestens die anforderungen dieses gesetzes ja aber das ist natürlich so ein bisschen das problem.
Wenn jetzt einfach jeder so eine corona app bastelt das ist unter umständen sehr schwierig wird,
zu prüfen dass sie sich auch genauso verhalten ja also wenn du pech hast installierst du dir halt die die fans die corona app mit backdoor aus irgendeinem aus irgendeinem playstore hast du nicht gesehen und da muss natürlich,
einerseits gesagt werden okay es gibt diese offenheit offenheit dass jemand eine andere baut aber es muss eben auch irgendeine form von zertifizierung geben damit hier nicht die ganze zeit einfach irgendwelche gebäck dort ein schatz opfers in.
Im umlauf gebracht werden verbesserung der genauigkeit zuwiderhandlungen und bus.
Gelder und geltungsbereich und geltung ich fand das auf jeden fall mal sehr interessant dass
dass man sich hier darüber gedanken macht und ich denke dass es generell wahrscheinlich keine schlechte idee ist hier ein gesetz für diesen spezifischen anwendungsfall von informationstechnologie zu schaffen indem.
Wieder eine reihe an befürchtungen sofort genommen werden.
Und ein paar pflöcke in den boden gerammt werden damit eben sich quasi das die die.
Nicht die standard-baderegeln die für irgendwelche datenzugriff und sonstiges gelten.
Hier greifen können insofern würde ich den autorin noch empfehlen noch spezifisch was dazu zu schreiben was hier irgendwie zugriff im rahmen von strafverfahren und sonstigen angeht.
Ich habe mir das jetzt nicht so im detail durchgelesen man muss natürlich auch sehen
kann natürlich jetzt auch noch dinge geben die sich jetzt wirklich noch erst ergeben das ist natürlich immer ein bisschen schwierig wenn man jetzt versucht da so einen deckel zu zu machen und auf einmal verbaut man sich dann die möglichkeit da nachzuarbeiten aber ich glaube
das soweit du das jetzt vorgetragen hat dass alles ganz sinnvolle feststellung sind die sich ja auch weitgehend mit der aktuellen entwicklung decken.
Die aktuelle entwicklung übrigens also ein beispiel für wie sich die aktuelle entwicklung dich dann teilweise überholt ist ja dieser zugriff der polizei auf infektionsstation,
ich hatte das ja hier auch in der sendung schon mal angesprochen dass es da fälle gab,
wenn ich mich jetzt nicht täusche in er in den wir nennt man sie denn politisch korrekt tim die die neuen bundesländer.
Achso weiß nicht aus deutschland.
In der ehemaligen ddr.
Ich habe den witz mit den neuen bundesländern erst erst gestern in dem anderen podcast gehört wurde gesagt wir nennen ach du bist in den neuen bundestag nein ich bin noch in den gebrauchten bundesländern.
Ok also genau der gab es ja dann auch schon fälle wo ihr eben sensible daten weitergegeben wurden.
Und in baden-württemberg hat der landesdatenschutzgesetze stefan brink,
festgestellt dass eben die klarnamen von corona infizierten personen an die polizei weitergegeben wurden,
und das hat ja eine das ist natürlich ein problem also ist seitdem offen grund gegangen eines problem was ich dann natürlich herausgestellt hat war das gesetz verstößt offenbar gegen die polizei,
ja weil das durften die gar nicht deswegen hat gibt es in baden-württemberg jetzt die verordnung des innen-und sozialministeriums zur verarbeitung personenbezogener daten zwischen gesundheitsbehörden und polizei.
In der genau geregelt wird das nämlich ab dienstag bei konkreten lässt die polizei auf die daten von gesundheitsämtern zugreifen darf um sich darüber zu informieren welche person mit dem koroner
virus infiziert sind und das wird für argumentiert damit dass die beamten rechtzeitig schutzvorkehrungen treffen.
Könnten wenn sie diesen personen begegnen.
Dann frage ich mich ernsthaft so leute wenn diese beamten da draußen rumrennen dann hoffe ich dass die ohnehin schutzvorkehrungen haben genauso wie alle anderen.
Menschen die wir als systemrelevant in irgendwelchen jobs rumrennen lassen und das sollte sich hoffentlich in keiner form ändern ob ein polizist.
Einem einer definitiv corona infizierten personen begegnet oder einer.
Vielleicht corona infizierten personen begegnet.
Es ist vor allem insofern vollkommen absurd also ich meine bis so eine information in so einer datenbank und dann wieder bei einem polizisten ist ja ist wahrscheinlich die infra infektionskrankheit dieser person bereits vorbei.
Ja ich meine wir reden hier von einem zeitraum von maximal einer woche.
Die wahrscheinlichkeit dass irgendjemand anderes denn nicht in dieser datenbank drin steht diese tatsächlich infektiös ist ist viel höher.
Ich meine das interessante ist ja du du was du bekommst ist die adresse also im prinzip den ein ort wo sich die person im zweifelsfall sowieso gerade aufhält.
Ja was machst du jetzt fährst dann nicht mehr hin also ich ich halte das für alles für für äußerst irre und ich hatte ja auch schon den fall angesprochen dass es eben
hier mir mir ein fall bekannt ist wo eine person eine auskunft sperre hatte.
Also man kann begründet eben zum beispiel sagen dass,
verfügen lassen dass eben bei einer adresse auskunft die daten nicht rausgegeben werden das machen menschen die von terroristen bedroht werden oder von was weiß ich irgendwelchen stalker oder so ja damit,
diese daten nicht an.
Missetäter gelangt zum beispiel an irgendwelche nazis bei der polizei die diese daten dann in irgendwelche todeslisten aufnehmen.
Und genau das ist natürlich dann hier der fall wenn du diese daten zum im rahmen deiner infekt deiner gesundheitlichen auseinandersetzung mit dem gesundheitsamt.
Dem gesundheitsamt gibst und sagst okay pass auf ich wohne an diesem und jenem geheimen ort und die sagen ey
polizei brandenburg wollte er nicht mal hier von folgenden personen mal die adressen sicherheitshalber haben nur damit ihr wisst wo die wohnen das ist also ich kann mir einfach nicht,
vorstellen dass das akzeptabel ist weil ich nicht ich glaube dass das argument,
das hier angebracht wird einfach mit der realität nichts zu tun hat in der sich eine infizierte person befindet nämlich sie ist eine woche lang infektiös maximal sie ist offenbar schon längst.
Diagnostiziert worden kurz
nach der diagnose ich glaube dann sind sowieso nur noch maximal vier tage die überhaupt noch ansteckend bist so ungefähr weil du ja schon den symptomen beginn hattest sonst wär's ja nicht getestet worden,
unter umständen ändert sich das mit einer corona app und dann bist du
wahrscheinlich zu hause in irgendeiner isolierung und diese daten die werden aber natürlich hier einfach mal der polizei gegeben ohne irgendwelche nennenswerten verfügung jeder nazi bei der polizei schreibt sie sich mal eben ab und die sind ja dann für immer,
in der welt ja und defacto bist du ja ungefähr zwei wochen später bist du der eine mensch den die polizei gefahrlos besuchen kann.
Also ich kann ich kann das.
Ich verstehe auch die logik nicht.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen es ist in keiner von.
Ist denn überhaupt irgendwo gesagt worden was denn diese maßnahmen der polizei dann sein sollen also was was was machen die ziehen sie sich da so ein marshmallow ganzkörperanzug anzug an oder was also.
Dass ich guck mal ob da in dieser verordnung noch etwas steht.
Heilungstext vielleicht veranstalten sie heilungs-
Also hier ich gucke mal in der was haben sie denn unter schutz da steht.
Soll ja helfen oder beten oder irgendwie so was.
Infektionsschutz datenschutz infektionsschutz infektionsschutz schutzmaßnahme so was haben sie denn für schutzmaßnahmen vorgesehen.
Also nee würde mich jetzt auch wundern wenn wenn sowas spezifiziert würde also schutz kommt hier nur als infektionsschutz.
Und datenschutz vor die daten aha ok,
die daten dürfen nur vom führungs- und lagezentrum des jeweils für den einsatz des polizeivollzugsdiensts zuständigen polizeipräsidiums im einzelfall
abgerufen werden soweit dies aus gründen des infektionsschutz erfördert erforderlich ist eins zum schutz der beamtinnen und beamten des polizeivollzugsdiensts vor ansteckung bei einsetzen,
mit anderen worten die kommen nicht zur anordnung durchführung überwachung.
Zur anordnung durchführung überwachung und zum vollzug von maßnahmen nach dem infektionsschutz gesetz das bedeutet also wenn du wenn du corona positiv bist.
Dann kriegst du ja tatsächlich eine anordnung nach infektionsschutz gesetz dich in quarantäne zu begeben und der verstoß dagegen ist ja auch strafbewehrte mit anderen worten man könnte diese daten auch nutzen damit die polizei mal regelmäßig guckt ob du auch hier brav quarantäne bist ne.
Oder doch mal kurz eben einkaufen.
Ja gut aber das ist natürlich das ist natürlich eine ganz andere nummer an der stelle also das ist ja dann in dem moment wo die quarantäne verordnet ist ist das ja dann auch ein.
Notiert da vorgang der nicht eigentlichen sinne was mit gesundheitsdaten zu tun hat.
Ja aber der ist halt bei das ist aber bei der da liegen die daten ja immer noch beim gesundheitsamt.
Verfolgung von straftaten oder aus seiner grundlage.
Ergangenen rechtsverordnung also das das bedeutet im prinzip nee genau verfolgen von straftaten und ordnungswidrigkeiten auf grundlage des infektionsschutz gesetzes also theoretisch wäre es ja.
Also ein mensch der.
Wenn ich das richtig laienhaft verstanden habe ein mensch der corona positiv ist und dem angeordnet wurde beglichen charakter der sich dem widersetzt und dann außerdem sagen wir von mir aus noch absichtlich andere ansteckt in diesem rahmen dürfen die daten verwendet werden.
Zur prüfung der haft oder unterbringungs- zeit sowie der erforderlichen seit der isolierten unterbringung in gewahrsam einrichtung und so weiter die abfrage darf nur erfolgen wenn das zuständige führungs- und lagezentrum sämtliche.
Unter absatz eins nummer eins genannten daten der betroffenen personen eingibt du musst also quasi nach der person suchen.
Und du kannst nicht einfach alle dir geben lassen okay.
Die erhobenen daten dürfen nur weiter verarbeitet werden soweit ist zur erreichung der unter absatz drei genannten zwecke erforderlich ist insbesondere dürfen die daten nur solchen personen
innerhalb des polizeivollzugsdiensts zur kenntnis gebracht werden deren informationen zu erreichung
dieser zwecke erforderlich ist die durch die abfrage erhobenen daten sind spätestens achtundvierzig stunden nach der abfrage von allen polizeidienststellen zu löschen.
Weiterverarbeitung zu anderen zwecken ist unzulässig okay immerhin muss man sagen die.
Missbrauchspotenzial sind erscheinen mir von dieser verordnung abgedeckt zu sein ich würde aber dennoch weiterhin sagen dass es.
Keinen dass es auf anhieb erstmal nicht sinnvoll zu sein scheint der polizei überhaupt diese daten zu geben weil sich die,
personen im zweifelsfall in dieser kurzen phase der ansteckblume zeit die im zweifelsfall schon hinter sich haben und sich in einer quarantäne befinden und was mit diesen daten natürlich am ende passieren wird ist irgendeine form von massenzucht.
Befürchten wir zumindest.
Ja wie gesagt ich kenne schon einen fall der wo der sagen wir mal der jetzt von dieser verordnung nicht gedeckt gewesen wäre.
Okay tja ja.
Ich hatte ja außerdem in einer der vorangegangenen folgen schon das corona hotel prognostiziert.
Ja ich wollte schon buchen aber hab die webseite nicht gefunden.
Hat er spahn gehört und hat sich überlegt.
Da müssen wir für diesen wirtschaftszweig müssen wir eine grundlage schaffen und am besten schaffen wir die natürlich indem wir ein immunität ausweis.
Schaffen und hat das dann in den entwurf eines zweiten gesetzes zum schutz der bevölkerung bei einer epidemie lage von nationaler tragweite aufgenommen.
In dieser verordnung
in diesem gesetz werden testung pflegekräfte prämien und andere sachen geregelt aber eben auch
die idee eines zertifizierten nachweisen immun gegen das korona virus zu sein und die sache ist dass es natürlich.
Ich habe ja schon gesagt dass ich mir relativ sicher bin dass das kommen wird und das problem bei so etwas ist natürlich dass dieser.
Nachweis mit.
Ganz krassen vorteilen verbunden sein wird mit anderen worten diesen nachweis nicht zu haben mit ganz krassen nachteilen verbunden sein wird das wiederum bedeutet dass menschen versuchen werden diesen nachweis zu fälschen.
Oder schnellstmöglich zu erlangen und wir haben eine ganze menge an menschen in unserer gesellschaft für die.
Das nicht so etwas wie ein optionales scherzchen wäre ja nämlich wenn du wenn du einmal die möglichkeiten.
Geld zu verdienen die du hast auf eine gewisse weise sich auf einen bestimmten sektor oder so konzentrieren und du keine besonderes kein besonders hohes einkommen hast dass es dann für dich eben eine frage des.
Ja der gesellschaftlichen teilhabe und des gesellschaftlichen überlebens wird einen immunität nachweis zu erlangen um deinen job wieder nachgehen zu können und was weiß ich deine familie zu zu ernähren.
Jetzt hat der herr spahn gar protest jetzt hat er den plan wieder auf eis gelegt das hatte aber beim g basierten kontakt tracing auch gemacht insofern also ich kann diese sparen.
Kochtechnische nicht ganz erkennen ne der der nimmt immer irgendwas brett das heißt an und letztlich liegt ist dann auf eis um dann zu gucken wie man es doch noch servieren kann ich bin mir dann also das ding ist nicht durch und ich.
Kann habt ihr auch gar keine patentlösung für weil ich eine einerseits sehr okay das hat total krasse negative konsequenzen.
Ich sehe aber auch nicht wie.
Also ich sehe nicht wie in dieser realität auf so etwas früher oder später dauerhaft verzichtet werden könnte.
Zumal du ja auch von der anderen seite her argumentieren kannst das bestimmte regeln,
aufrecht erhalten werden also bestimmte beschränkungen kontaktfreudig et cetera also das was wir derzeit was derzeit alle betrifft dazu das natürlich in dem moment wo es faktisch nicht mehr alle,
betrifft weil die voraussetzungen eben nicht für alle dieselben sind dann noch bei bestimmten leuten aufrecht erhalten werden muss mal dass er dann eben
schon richtig sagt es auch wirtschaftliche nachteile hat et cetera also ist ja nicht nur dieses vorteil haben sondern eben keinen nachteil haben worauf man ja gewisser hinsicht auch.
Gut recht will ich jetzt nicht sagen aber anspruch empfindet und deswegen wird sich diese debatte mit steigender,
immunität in der gesellschaft sicherlich neu stellen.
Genau das ist richtig und dann hast du wirklich also ich finde es eine wirklich eine fiese.
Eine fiese herausforderung einerseits willst du es gibt klare wünsche zu sagen okay wir möchten die menschen nicht.
Wir können die menschen auch gar nicht ohne begründung ihrer freiheiten berauben und jede person die nach die irgendwie eine korona infektion überstanden hat der kannste de facto,
gibt kein keine reale grundlage mehr der irgendetwas zu verbieten.
Was allerdings in diese diskussion auch mit reinkommt und was glaube ich auch der hauptgrund ist warum man jetzt den immunität ausweis einfach ablehnen muss.
Ist gar nicht so sehr die angst vor dem korolla hotel sondern einfach dass es dafür derzeit einfach noch gar keine wissenschaftlich gesicherte grundlage gibt es gibt die
annahme dass es eine dass dass man nach einer infektion auch,
längere zeit und auch eine annahme vermutlich auch zu hundert prozent immun ist aber.
Das ist noch nicht sicher dass es zu hundert prozent ist davon geht man derzeit aus und keiner kann sagen wie lange diese immunität anhält also es gibt bestimmte viren wenn man sich anschaut.
Gibt bestimmte krankheiten da impft man sich einmal im leben und das war's so aber eine masernimpfung aktion.
Kannst du halt auch noch später heranziehen wenn du nicht sagst nach ich weiß es nicht ganz genau zehn fünfzehn jahre sollte man,
auf jeden fall auch noch mal sich eine auffrischung holen,
und das ist einfach eine information die existiert derzeit nicht das heißt würdest du jetzt so einen ausweis machen und irgendwas behaupten was wissenschaftlich noch überhaupt gar nicht belegbar ist,
da kommst du da irgendwie auch nicht weit mit weil das würde dann zweifel nur bedeuten dass du dann auch noch leute in sozusagen in situationen rein schickst indem du ihn das erlaubst dir aber eigentlich viel zu gefährlich sind.
Das erscheint mir bei ehrlich gesagt nicht das nicht unbedingt ein besonderes problem zu sein weil wenn ich mir heute ein impfpass anschaue,
da steht auch nicht drin dass ich gegen irgendetwas immun bin sondern da steht drin wenn ich die impfung erhalten habe.
Ja gut aber da ist ja schon mal bewiesen worden dass diese impfung eine immunität herstellen kann mit einer bestimmten sicherheit.
Ja und jetzt würde ich argumentieren es gibt wenn.
Die gesellschaft eine debatte über ein immunität ausweis führen möchte wäre es im zweifelsfall nicht klug mit dieser debatte darauf zu warten dass diese immunität jetzt bewiesen ist oder nicht,
im zweifelsfall ist es besser die debatte jetzt schon zu führen,
wenn für den fall dass dann irgendeiner um die kurve kommt und sagt übrigens immunität dass das was du jetzt nennst wenn ihr letztendlich parameter,
dieses ausweises.
Die sofern er dann käme ja aber über den jetzt hier diskutiert wird was nicht unbedingt heißt dass es schlecht wäre diese debatte jetzt zu führen.
Also von mir aus auch mit negativem ergebnis ne also oder gerne mit negativem ergebnis.
Ich werde mich nicht gegen die debatte ich sage nur,
es ist halt ein klares argument gegen ein immunität ausweis aus dem man irgendwas ableiten kann auf basis einer westlage aus der man noch überhaupt nichts ableiten kann so das
das ist halt der grund warum ich denke dass die diskussion zu diesem zeitpunkt gestorben ist die wird also zumindest diese diese planung gestorben ist die diskussion ist da dieses auch völlig in ordnung dass sie da ist weil es ist wieder mal ein ein abwägen und
da müssen wir schauen ich denke wir werden ohnehin jetzt in eine zeit kommen wo der impfpass eine ganz neue bedeutung bekommt,
bisher war das so ein bisschen so dieses zerfleddert.
Habe ich auch noch irgendwo.
Hier genau liegt irgendwo rum wo ist denn mein impfpass eigentlich weil ich muss jetzt mal nach französisch-guayana fliegen so weißt du wo du mal deine gelbfieber-impfung nachweisen muss
oder du fliegst halt irgendwo nach afrika und malaria das war so ein bisschen so die ausnahme geschichte und jetzt ist das halt unter umständen etwas was eben jetzt hier konkret für unser weiteres zusammenleben eine gewisse relevanz hat,
deswegen,
nehme ich an dass wir da änderungen haben werden und ich sehe schon eine logbuch netzpolitik folge wo wir uns über den digitalen impfpass die einführung in deutschland die tolle gesundheitskarte auch noch immer unterhalten müssen.
Auf ja auf jeden fall also dass wir das wird thema und ich ich sehe nicht dass dass diese debatte damit beendet ist dass der spahn das jetzt mal gerade aufs eis liegt weil was er de facto macht ist er wird er wird,
im zweifelsfall genau deine argumentation gefolgt sein zu sagen na ja okay so wichtig ist das zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
anfang mai noch nicht dass ich mir dadurch meinen zweites gesetz zum schutz der bevölkerung bei einer epidemie lage von nationaler tragweite verhageln lasse ich habe ja noch drei vier schuss,
und dann wird er sich ganz einfach überlegt haben dann nehmen wir das in den sack nicht mit auf dann nehmen wir das halt in den in major release version drei gar kein problem.
Naja im idealfall versucht er auch nur das richtige zu tun.
So dann haben wir eine gute nachricht.
Ja es gibt gute nachrichten und diesmal kommt sie von der logbuch netzpolitik berichtete,
das ja die toplevel domain dot org.
So verscherbelt werden sollte wie das mit domains gemeinhin stattfindet man sucht sich ein meistbietenden unternehmen was bereit ist für das recht,
alle domains unter dieser domänen zu verkloppen viel geld hinlegt und dann,
tut sie das einfach und dann bestimmt schlicht und ergreifend der marktwert was man für diese paar beide die irgendwo in eine textdatei eingetragen werden zu bezahlen hat.
Und ja jetzt war wohl der druck groß genug
dass der vorstand tatsächlich diesen verkauf der eigentlich geplant war am dreißigsten april also vor knapp einer woche die zustimmung verweigert hätte weil sie festgestellt haben dass das ja im öffentlichen.
Interesse sei.
Das ist krass weil der vorstand ist nicht derjenige der diesen verkauf gemacht hätte
nimmt es wäre nämlich die eishockey gewesen also quasi ich wusste gar nicht dass die dass das die ican oder der icon da irgendwie ein vetorecht hat.
Scheint offensichtlich so zu sein oder zumindest hinter die politischen macht factory so gelagert dass sie eishockey jetzt nicht hat einfach durchstarten können.
Also sie haben einfach gesagt die ican board the jack the post change auf control.
Anticor version request.
Public interesse registriere mit also der der des ican hat gesagt ja okay wir stimmen den einfach nicht zu dass ihr das verkauft ja und jetzt bleibt quasi die internet society.
Mit mit dieser toplevel domain.
Da sitzen und hat halt nicht die milliarde us-dollar die sie dafür ganz gerne gehabt hätte
und gleichzeitig das unternehmen capital das dafür gegründet wurde diese registriert zu kaufen und sie dann mit gewinn absicht zu betreiben die geht halt leer aus,
also das bleibt das das bleibt halt ein also capital hat kein kapital.
Oder von mir aus haben sie capital aber keine org domain.
Auch fuck kann ich dazu nur sagen ich meine wie kann man sich internet society nennen und dann.
Die optimale verkaufen.
Und dann verscherbelt man da einfach so ein kronjuwelen irgendwie das gehört uns halt allen und meine gewisser hinsicht ist dann diese dort domain auch wirklich noch so das letzte was daran erinnert wie früher mal so im internet mal so zuging
ne
Eine eines der letzten relikte eines eines community internets des des ja okay gut.
Also um das noch kurz zusammenzufassen traurig oder dagegen waren ja vor allem die eigner innen von.
Dort org domains die eben fürchteten dass ihre toplevel domain registriert jetzt eben mit gewinn absicht betrieben wird und damit dann eben also die wollen die milliarde ja wieder haben und dass sie dann eben im zweifelsfall.
Ich hätte dafür zahlen müssen mein freund ich hätte dafür zahlen.
Wer hätte es bezahlt die ngos hätten das bezahlt.
Genau der kleine mann die metaebene.
Eine kleine tipp.
Wie viel oktober hast du na.
Kann ich dir leider auf anhieb nicht genau sagen es sind auf jeden fall mehrere.
So viele sind das ja okay ich habe mindestens zwei vielleicht habe ich auch noch mehr das weiß ich nicht aber ich glaube zwei war's egal sondern hacker hat da gefunden hacker gefunden.
Ich fand heute also heute diese überschrift fand ich so geil haftbefehl gegen russischen hacker und haftbefehl ist ja so ein so ein prollo rapper.
Und da habe ich mir irgendwie so ein battle vorgestellt.
Und habe mir so gedacht so da kann es auch nur gewinner geben aber es ist tatsächlich die rede von einem.
Tatsächlich ein haftbefehl.
Haftbefehl.
Irgendwo ich mache dich fertig warten wir mal ab.
Platz explode.
Okay so wir haben es tatsächlich hat die bundesrepublik deutschland ein haftbefehl erlassen und zwar gegen einen herrn bading,
dessen ich glaube im süddeutschen artikel stand auch nochmal so quasi in deutscher lautschrift wie man den namen ausspricht.
Also ich habe dimitri buddy gelesen.
Ja der heißt nämlich dimitri sehr gerne bading dimitri serge gewinnsparen
der ist neunundzwanzig jahre alt jetzt und geboren in kurs
in russland und ihm wird's für last gelegt dass er am siebten mai zweitausendfünfzehn um dreizehn uhr neunundzwanzig eine schadsoftware mit dem namen vvs excel zunächst erstellt und dann um dreizehn uhr einunddreißig eingesetzt und gesteuert
habe und das ist diese schadsoftware diente dem angriff auf den,
bundestag zu der zeit also wir reden hier von bundestags heck zweitausendfünfzehn der nämlich dann am elften mai.
Fast zwei wochen nach beginn des angriffs.
Dem bundesamt für verfassungsschutz aufgefallen ist denn das es wurde festgestellt dass ein.
Für die gruppe fancy bär also achtundzwanzig bekannter kommando control plötzlich mit zwei servern in deutschland kommunizierte und die sich im bundestag befanden.
Und ich finde das sehr schön also diesen artikel muss man auch einfach mal zitieren ist ein artikel von florian flade und georg maskulin georg maske ist ich würde sagen seit mindestens,
zehn fünfzehn jahren der investigativ journalist der immer die exklusiven.
Geschichten der sagen wir mal deutschen strafverfolgungsbehörden und geheimdienste auf höchster ebene hat ja also der erstaunlich der ganz besonders gute investigative methoden und,
sagen wir mal von der einordnung her wie er das berichtet würde ich auch dafür sorgen dass er die richtigen methoden hat denn es war eine digitale abwehrschlacht wie sie deutschland bis dato noch nicht erlebt hatte,
zwischenzeitlich wurde das gesamte it-system des bundestages heruntergefahren erst am zwanzigsten mai zwanzig fünfzehn war die attacke beendet mindestens sechzehn gigabyte daten sollen bis dahin abgeflossen sein darunter zigtausende e-mails von abgeordneten.
Ja also man sieht insgesamt eine sehr positive berichterstattung hier über den die bemühungen der deutschen sicherheitsbehörden.
Der verdacht fiel damals eben schnell auf achtundzwanzig fancy bär eine gruppe die eben,
ja aus russland stammt und aus russland operiert und der man eine nähe zum kremmel,
nachsagt ja das ist eine gruppe da gibt's ja dieses traumhafte putin zitat das beste putin zitat ever ich glaube auch das hatten wir hatten thorsten und ich in unserem vortrag das mit dem hacker sind sowie künstler die stehen morgens auf.
Und wenn es ihnen gut geht malen sie ihre bilder und wenn sie dann irgendwie sehen wie russland in der welt behandelt wird und ihren gerechten beitrag leisten wollen dann haben wir damit nichts zu tun
das ist ein sehr schönes signal an an die russische hacker schafft aber achtundzwanzig ist.
Und das denke ich kann man jetzt auch kaum noch in zweifel ziehen eine einheit des russisches russisches militärgeheimdienstes nämlich die einheit sechsundzwanzig eins.
Fünfundsechzig und in diesem fall.
Wenn wir üblicherweise solche.
Aufklärungen von solchen angriffen hören dann hört man üblicherweise sowas wie glaubhafte nachrichtendienstliche hinweise also die die amerikaner haben uns gesagt dass wird schon so gewesen sein,
aber wenn manche tatsächlich in die strafverfolgung gehen möchte dann kannst du nicht irgendwie sagen die amerikaner haben uns das gesagt sondern du musst tatsächlich,
beweise vorlegen auch vor gericht und das ist sehr interessant es war mir damals gar nicht so aufgefallen ich gehe auch nicht davon aus dass logbuch netzpolitik darüber berichtet hat denn.
Im april zwanzig haben niederländische ermittler eine ein paar fancy bär leute.
In ihrem land.
Festgehalten die waren mit diplomaten pässen eingereist konnten deshalb nicht festgenommen werden und die hatten sich offenbar.
Das o p c,
angeschaut also die die organisation for the provision auf call und also die chemiewaffen produktionsort station und der verdacht besteht dass sie.
Irgendwie vor hatten die zu hacken ja weiß der geier so die theorie auf jeden fall haben die niederländischen ermittler die eben am dreizehnten april zwanzigachtzehn festgesetzt und den laptops und mobiltelefone weggenommen.
Und die stellten sich nachher als wahre schatztruhe heraus auch für ermittler in deutschland denn durch das material was sie auf diesem geräten gefunden haben haben sie eben wertvolle informationen über diese,
einheit aha jetzt jetzt hier ist sie auf einmal einundsechzig fünfundsechzig gerade habe ich noch.
Sechsundzwanzig ein sechs fünf bis.
Ja in dem ok aber auf jeden fall diese einheit gefunden und eben auch zu dem guten dimitri sehr gerne wird spanien.
Und
ja offenbar haben sie damit noch zwei jahre daran weiter gearbeitet bis sie jetzt tatsächlich genug beweise hatten die sie eben generalbundesanwalt in karlsruhe.
Zu einem haftbefehl gereicht haben das was mich daran jetzt ernsthaft interessiert ist aber das steht da natürlich wieder nicht also ich meine wenn du ein russischer.
Cyber hacker bist ne.
Beim und du reißt mit dem diplomatischen pass ein was irgendwie so der knallrote tage zimmer auf deinem auf deiner stirn ist ja.
Machst du das ohne verschlüsselte festplatte masse nimmst du da überhaupt einen computer mit.
Oder telefone wo was drauf ist.
Hast du da nicht also junge junge ich hätte einen interessanten vortrag über obs für euch ja das ist aber das wasser wieder
andererseits auch sagen weil die die die haben ja eigentlich selten anlass zu ob sie weil ja den klar sein kann dass ihnen für ihre aktivitäten nicht wirklich was passiert
und jetzt ist natürlich die andere sache offenbar der,
dimitri berlin ist war nicht einer dieser reisenden aber er.
Stand offenbar mit denen in kontakt ist jetzt quasi hier so ein kollateralschaden in dem fall ne,
aber also ich ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt hätte jetzt nicht gedacht dass militärische militärische operierende hacker ernsthaft mit irgendwelchen beweismitteln im kofferraum durchs durchs.
Feines land fahren.
Aber haben sie wohl gemacht oder vielleicht haben sie auch einfach schlechte passwörter gehabt oder so ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass vielleicht die deutschen ermittlungsbehörden dann doch auch mal sich ein bisschen mühe gegeben haben diese beweismittel auszuwerten.
Also der herr wird ja auch vom fbi gesucht das gibt dann eine schöne most,
silberline im im netz mit foto von dem jungen hat
und ja eben wird halt auch vorgeworfen dieser ganzen election madleen geschichte zwanzig sechzehn mit beteiligt gewesen zu sein also gehört zumindest zu den elf angeklagten.
Mit anderen worten dass der jemals sein haftbefehl in deutschland vollstreckt bekommt ist äußerst unwahrscheinlich
denn sollte der sollte irgendwann einmal ein westlicher staat den guten dimitri in die finger kriegen dann reist er auf jeden fall in die usa.
Und nicht nach deutschland das kennen wir ja.
Kommt drauf an ob wir die trump sache dann ausgegangen ist also wenn der trump nicht mehr präsident ist dann geht es auf jeden fall ganz schnell.
Ansonsten dürft ihr kein interesse daran haben dass das aufgearbeitet wird.
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich meine dem dem julian assange hat er dann auch keine solidarität erwiesen.
Dann wäre ich denke wir mal am ende dieser sendung es gab ja noch ein vorfall der,
jetzt nicht in den netzpolitischen bereich fällt aber sehr decke auch in die.
Thematische auseinandersetzungen mit dem mit gesellschaftlichen strömungen und dem corona virus dazu schreibt uns nils,
als ich von der attacke auf das zdf team vom von abdelkarim hörte habe ich mich,
einfach mal hingesetzt und drauf los gemischt logbuch netzwerk begleitet mich seit einigen jahren treu und ist stets ein quelle der aufklärung freude und bereicherung wahrscheinlich ist es auch,
dies was mich am ende feststellen dies dass ihr stark in den remix eingeflossen seid,
also was ist passiert ein team der heute show wurde in berlin angegriffen.
Und ich glaube die wollten dort eine die hygiene demo oder besuchen oder war das so.
Ich vermute mal dass das der anlass war die waren allerdings nicht als heute show team erkennbar nach eigenen aussagen sind aber dann eben von so einem blog von ich glaube fünfzehn,
irgendwie verkleidet vermummten weiß ich nicht genau
aufgemischt worden das fernsehteam hatte drei security-leute dabei die,
du weißt schon für sich genommen krass ist die sich auch wohl voll eingebracht haben ein tontechniker musste wohl trotzdem enorm dran glauben also dem ist wohl,
brutal ins gesicht getreten worden etcetera dann haben sich die security-leute da reingeworfen zu dritt gegen fünfzehn natürlich auch nicht unbedingt ideal bestückt
und dann ging's da wohl ganz fenster zur sache mit mindestens fünf verletzten
zur bewertung werden das nun sei bin ich mal ganz zurückhaltend da habe ich jetzt verschiedenste sachen gehört und wieder jetzt auch gar.
Gar nichts vermuten aber ist eigentlich auch am ende vollkommen egal also abgesehen davon dass man sowieso leute nicht angreift ist es natürlich hier nochmal
besonders perfide weil man einfach schwer den eindruck haben muss dass die eben speziell angegriffen wurden weil
sie presse sind so und wer da jetzt gerade kein interesse daran hatte kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Man sollte schon noch ergänzen dass es halt die heute show also nicht also es ist es ist ein journalistisches satirischer erzeugnis was als solches natürlich immer noch mal schwerer zu verdauen ist
und wir erinnern uns an angriffe in paris auf charlie hebdot
und das ist natürlich also ich meine das ist sehr wichtig gerade diese satirischen erzeugnisse und zu schützen weil sie es eigentlich sind die,
den.
Den waren den waren den fahren journalismus den waren widerstand und die die so eine art.
Unverbindlich blick auf die politik irgendwie bewahren können oft.
Oh ja vor allem gerade in letzter zeit also ich weiß nicht ob du mal heute schon gesehen hast den letzten wochen ist ich habe viel lachen müssen wirklich also es ist deutlich ist es vor allem ich meine ich hadere wirklich mit deutschem,
fernseher enorm so und musste dieses gefühl überhaupt nicht mehr unterdrücken.
Also ich kann dazu nur sagen also die heute show sorry das war es jetzt seit längerem schon nicht mehr irgendwie
also habe ich noch nie geguckt habe ich auch noch nie drüber gelacht und das ist für mich jetzt tatsächlich nicht die die speerspitze des politischen humors,
muss ich muss ich wirklich einfach mal sagen aber gerade deshalb und auch sonst ist es,
kein grund diese menschen anzugreifen und einfach absolut falsch ja.
Und deswegen gilt selbstverständlich unsere solidarität hier den angegriffenen.
Und niemand anders denn gerade also ich meine das macht ja leider.
Das das macht er den reiz an satire und journalismus aus dass es eben nicht immer allen gefällt und dass man es genau deshalb.
Sich gefallen lassen muss und sich damit auseinandersetzt genauso wie wir uns hier mit den ponys satiriker aus der faz auseinandersetzen und den ich mit einer stange auf den kopf hauen.
Wobei ich nicht weiß ob die das nicht mit uns machen würden ehrlich gesagt.
Meinst du oh gott.
Ja genau aber sorry wir schweifen ab zu diesem.
Thema hat also nils von der einhorn standard dresden ein remix gemacht und den spielen wir als auto außerdem danke ich dann natürlich nils.
Und richard und matze und michael und vanessa.
Und allen anderen spenderinnen und spendern und sonstigen unterstützern tipp gebern wohlmeinenden und zitieren und überhaupt allen anderen auch,
insofern habt eine schöne entspannte woche und dann hören wir uns wieder.
Tschau tschau.